[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Madison
is with us to start off this hour in
Atlanta Georgia hi Madison welcome to
the
show hi Dave hi John um thank you so
much for taking my call sure what's up
um so I'm in a predicament um that I've
actually made myself um I got married uh
second marriage for both of us um uh not
quite 6 years ago um and at that time um
I had been through a pretty bad divorce
and had a pretty um uh traumatic first
marriage so definitely was healing from
that and met this wonderful man so nice
to me and kind to me and um I just felt
head over heels in love with him um I
knew he was broke I knew he didn't have
any money and that that just didn't
matter to me he was just so nice to me
and I loved being treated nice so um we
got married um I did have him sign a
prenup because I was uh expecting to
inherit a large amount of money from my
parents estate at some point I hadn't at
that time but um I knew that that would
be in the future and uh so he did sign a
prenuptual agreement and didn't have any
problems with that um however I started
our relationship with just paying all
the time I I paid for everything we'd go
out for dinner I would pay um I already
had a place where I lived that I paid
for and uh you know etc etc so I I
understand how I've kind of set a
pattern um and at the time it didn't
bother me and you know I might want I
also want to add this man's a Christian
man he knows the word of God um you know
we really I really have put this in
God's hands and asked for his help um
but um I just I just can't figure out
where why there's just there's no Spirit
of generosity with with him he just I've
brought up several times you know can
you please pitch in just kick in I don't
expect half and half I have plenty of
money I don't I don't need his money
it's just on principle just I just need
to know that I'm not just the only one
that's supporting us I feel like I'm I'm
the bread winner he doesn't earn an
income he he did we are both retired now
um he does not have any retirement he
how old are you go I'm 60 he's 64 okay
um he took uh he took social security
early he was working at that time and
then
um when you stay when you start taking
social security you you're you can only
work so many hours you can only make so
much money um so that knocked his out
you know availability down to where he
really couldn't work very much but since
then we've both retired and relocated
and um so do you feel like the core
question
is um I I think I'm just trying to
figure out if um if I'm being taken
advantage of is this just something
where I'm I'm being you know I've
brought something up several times and I
just nothing changes nothing it just
stays the same and I don't know if I
what I guess what my next step should be
as far as hold on this this is this
isn't a money issue this is a respect
issue you don't respect the man that
you're married
to because like I I I bring
home I I I bring home a quote unquote
income to the house but my wife my God
Almighty if she disappeared the house
would go away so I don't look at her and
say wow you're not contributing to this
thing and I'm paying for dinner all the
time because my money is our
money right and and the home that she
keeps and runs and her small business
like that's ours too but there's a
mutual respect
there so this doesn't have to do with
money and you mentioned
earlier you don't want a thing you don't
want your marriage to be where you're
paying for everything it is that is the
world you set up so yeah the only thing
you can do from this point forward is to
create something new but this is a
respect issue this isn't a I just need
him to pitch in issue have you been very
clear what you need or has it been a ah
you know like man I sure am paying for a
lot and he might be thinking well it's
our money have you been very clear with
him I'm I'm not no I'm I'm very afraid
of Confrontation I get very nervous
about uh talking about something like
this about and then you end up in
resentment land because you spend a ton
of time having imaginary conversations
in your head don't you yes oh I do
that's cruel and unfair to him and doubt
yeah yes so if you're going to
on your brain too yeah if if if if
you're going to be mad at him he at
least deserves to know what he could do
give him a path back to relationship
because right now he married somebody
with a lot of money and he might think
he's fulfilling his duties as your
husband by being the fun loving guy that
just whatever whatever part in a Parry
he needs to know you don't respect
him yeah I do I do love him and I don't
want uh I don't want anything to end I
what does he need to do to be a person
that you would respect because he
doesn't need to work you guys are
retired no it's not a work it's not a
work ethic thing what is it that he's
supposed to do that makes him valid in
your
mind I think just pitching in say I
don't know ,000 dollar a month something
something so from what where's he got
money he has Social Security money and
he gets other money from guys don't have
your finances combined at
all um we do have a joint checking
account but he's never put any money in
it so no I mean but does he have an
Avenue to do
that he could yeah he he could he could
put money in there yeah because he's on
the he's on the account but if he's
looking at your vast amount of money in
that account and he looks at his ply his
ply um government
check yeah see what I'm saying like he
needs to know and I again I I think he's
going to put $1,000 in that account and
that's not what the issue is going to
be yeah if he started depositing $1,000
a month in that account you'd be right
back here in six
months I don't know if I would be I
don't it's really it's to me it's like
you just said it's not about money it's
more about um respect and I think
because this has gone on for so long and
you know I've allowed it to go on so
long and this p pattern's been set now
um I want to rewrite the rules I guess
well since y'all are married y'all get
to rewrite them together right and so I
think it's a matter of sitting down and
having a conversation and say hey we've
been married for a few years um I need
you to do this to have me have positive
respectful feelings towards you and what
can I do for you so that you can have
positive respectful feelings towards me
let's put all of it on the table M let's
give each other a chance success yeah
100% of what you don't say he can't hear
right
yeah I've been married 43 years I'm
still working on that Dave I am too man
I am
too the things that are in Sharon's head
that I have never heard are amazing but
you're in trouble for them I'm always in
TR you better fix them what's wrong
nothing create your free every dollar
budget today the simplest way to budget
for your life